Transcription: Viji Gowri
Relecteur: eric vautier
« Fais-lui juste passer l’année. »
On me parle là de Teva,
un petit garçon que
j’allais accueillir dans ma classe.
Je ne le connaissais pas encore,
mais on venait de me l’étiqueter
comme cancre.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’il n’arrivait pas à se démarquer
dans les deux intelligences
les plus mises en avant
dans notre système éducatif :
l’intelligence verbale-linguistique
qui est notre capacité
à maîtriser les structures des langues
et l’intelligence logico-mathématique
qui est notre capacité à calculer,
ordonner et comparer.
Howard Gardner a défini
huit différents types d’intelligences.
Huit,
et j’adore
la métaphore de Bruno Hourst
qui dit que nous naissons tous
avec ces huit fleurs d’intelligence.
Huit fleurs
que nous arrosons tous les jours,
grâce à nos actions avec notre entourage
et notre environnement.
Si nous pouvons arroser nos fleurs,
il y en a comme dans n’importe quel jardin
qui sont bien plus développées
que les autres,
des fleurs qui sont plus grandes
que les autres.
On les appelle
les intelligences dominantes.
Après quelques semaines d’observation,
je remarque que Teva
a pour intelligence dominante
l’intelligence kinesthésique.
C’est celle qui nous permet
d’être agile avec notre corps
et avec les objets qui nous entourent.
On retrouve cette intelligence
notamment chez les sportifs,
les mécaniciens
mais également chez les chirurgiens.
Après des semaines de travail - des mois -
en commun avec Teva,
étant reconnu
dans son intelligence dominante,
il a repris confiance en lui et a pu
s’ouvrir aux autres apprentissages,
notamment ceux qui sont les plus
encensés dans notre système éducatif.
« Oh lala-lala-lalala Vairea,
ne te laisse pas faire par cette petite.
Elle a un sacré caractère. »
On me parle là de Tiaré,
une petite fille de cinq ans
que j’allais avoir dans ma classe.
Si on peut arroser
nos fleurs d’intelligence
pour les faire grandir,
il arrive malheureusement
qu’on en délaisse,
qu’on ne s’occupe pas du tout d’elles.
Et après quelques jours d’observation,
je remarque que la fleur d’intelligence
intra-personnelle de Tiaré
n’est encore qu’à l’état de pousse.
Or c’est une fleur importante
et nécessaire à stimuler
dès le plus jeune âge,
parce qu’elle nous permet
de prendre confiance en nous,
de nous connaître,
de nous fixer des objectifs à atteindre
et de prendre en main
notre vie et nos apprentissages.
Comment demander à une enfant de cinq ans,
en plein combat intérieur,
d’apprendre à lire et à écrire ?
Après des mois de travail,
beaucoup de patience,
mais surtout beaucoup,
beaucoup d’amour,
Tiaré a développé
sa fleur d’intelligence intra-personnelle.
Elle a repris confiance en elle,
elle était plus posée
et a pu s’ouvrir
aux apprentissages
de la lecture et de l’écriture.
Une autre intelligence
qui est très importante à stimuler
et à développer dès le plus jeune âge,
est l’intelligence interpersonnelle.
C’est l’intelligence qui nous permet
d’entrer en relation avec les autres.
Je me rappelle un atelier à l’école.
Les élèves devaient faire
un exercice de lecture
et pour valider leur exercice, ils
devaient se faire filmer par un élève -
pas filmer -
se faire prendre en photo par un élève.
Et là, à ma grande surprise,
j’ai vu mon petit Michel, cinq ans,
s’épanouir complètement.
Il est allé bien au-delà
de ce qui lui était demandé ;
car il n’a pas fait que
prendre en photo ses camarades.
Il les a guidés,
il les a conseillés
et il les a encouragés
à ne serait-ce que commencer l’exercice.
Michel
qui semblait
complètement
perdu,
passif
dans ses apprentissages,
était devenu acteur
parce qu’il pouvait évoluer
dans ce domaine,
dans cette intelligence
qui lui était propre.
Il a pu ainsi aider ses camarades
et s’aider lui-même.
Ce que j’adore avec
la théorie des intelligences multiples,
c’est que rien n’est fixe,
rien n’est figé.
Comme dans un jardin, les fleurs
évoluent au gré des saisons.
Victoria, la première fois que je l’ai vue
dans ma classe, elle avait cinq ans.
Son intelligence dominante était
l’intelligence verbale-linguistique.
Je l’ai revue cinq ans plus tard
et à ma grande surprise,
elle avait développé
une autre intelligence.
Elle évoluait dans un espace qu’elle
ne connaissait que depuis cinq minutes.
Pour un jeu, elle avait les yeux bandés.
Elle devait
marcher et retrouver ses camarades
qui frappaient dans des cailloux.
Et je l’ai vue
évoluer sereinement,
marcher,
se diriger.
« OK. Là, il y a le mur, donc ça veut
dire que l’escalier est là. OK.
Voilà…
Et donc...
OK... Et ah voilà, la fin est là. Hop ! »
Elle avait développé
son intelligence visuo-spatiale.
C’est l’intelligence
qui nous permet nous de représenter
le monde dans toutes ses dimensions.
On la retrouve notamment
chez les peintres,
les sculpteurs,
mais également chez les architectes.
Lors de ce jeu,
Victoria n’a pas fait
que stimuler de façon ludique
son intelligence visuo-spatiale,
elle a également stimulé
son intelligence musicale-rythmique.
C’est notre capacite à écouter les sons,
les reproduire
mais également à ressentir les vibrations.
Dans toutes les civilisations,
on retrouve une trace de la musique.
C’est donc qu’elle est
importante pour l’être humain.
Et pourtant,
elle ne représente qu’une petite partie
des apprentissages à l’école.
Mon dernier fils a deux ans et demi
et il est plutôt naturaliste.
Il aime évoluer dehors.
Il aime la nature,
les plantes, les animaux,
mais également les étoiles et la Lune.
C’est d’ailleurs dehors
qu’il a voulu apprendre à marcher.
Le soir quand il s’endort, il veut voir
la Lune, il veut voir les étoiles ;
et donc pour l’aider à développer
ses autres intelligences,
je le laisse évoluer.
Je prends en considération
son intelligence dominante
et petit à petit, je lui apprends
le nom des couleurs, le nom des plantes ;
je lui fais remarquer
le bruit de la nature
et ainsi tout se passe bien.
Il est beaucoup plus serein.
Ma question en tant que maman :
comment ça va se passer
quand il sera à l’école ?
Quand on lui demandera
de rester assis à l’intérieur
à regarder le tableau
alors qu’il sera préoccupé
par ce qu’il se passe dehors ?
« Pourquoi les nuages,
pourquoi telle couleur ?
Le petit chat qui est dehors,
est-ce qu’il a sa maman ?
Qu’est-ce qu’il se passe dehors ? »
Non, il faudra qu’il reste focalisé
à l’intérieur.
Ma question en tant que maman est :
comment cela va se passer
quand on va le noter
sur sa capacite à grimper à un arbre
alors que c’est un magnifique
poisson rouge ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)